pour beaucoup vous allez rester l'homme
d'Helsinki bonjour laadj dukouré bonjour
l'homme d'Helsinki c'était à ce
moment-là une médaille d'or celle du 11
m comme champion du monde on attendait
ça depuis Stéphane Diagana et vous
l'avez fait c'était al je va pas vous
miner quand même enfin c'était vous avez
presque pas changé c'était quand même il
y a presque 20 ans la did courouré j'ai
un peu plus de cheveux oui c'est vrai
que ça fait bah maintenant 20 ans et ça
a été bah le un objectif de vie je
dirais et puis bah on l'a atteint et
sachant que bah Stéphane Diagana était
fait partie de mes modèles ouais ça m'a
voilà ça m'a très très motivé et puis
puis voilà on essaie de de suivre son
cours et mais c'est vrai que 2005 ça a
été une très très grande année et j'ai
eu la chance d'être en équipe de France
avec lui sur la fin de sa carrière ouais
et il fallait bah tout simplement de
prendre le témoin et continuer c'est le
cas de le dire parce que le témoin vous
l'avez pris aussi parce que vous vous
faisiez partie de l'équipe du 4 x 100
vra avec pognon avec de l'épine avec
Dovi c'était presque une génération
bénie de l'athlétisme et du sprint en
tout cas français quand on regarde avec
du recul comme ça ouais on avait une
grosse génération quand même une très
très grosse génération et puis bah bah
moi je suis super content d'être dans de
faire partie de cette génération on a un
peu cassé le le jeu comme on dit le
moule en tout cas on a cassé le jeu on a
fait des performances et puis euh on
appelle ça comme ça dans le milieu on
cassé le jeu
et aujourd'hui bah on est un peu
nostalgique de tout ça on se dit
pourquoi on était aussi fort et
aujourd'hui on a un peu de mal mais bon
alors on va parler d'aujourd'hui mais
d'abord ça existe pas les générations
spontanées ça veut dire que à un moment
ensemble des gens qui avaient des
aptitudes ont été repérés accompagnés et
sont devenus des champion qu'est-ce qui
dans l'environnement qui a été le vôre
dans votre enfance parce que la piste
d'atelé c'est quelque chose qu'on
appréende en sortant de l'école parce
qu'on en a une à côté de la maison et
cetera qu'est-ce qui fait qu'à un moment
donné vous vous êtes dit c'est là que je
vais aller alors qu'en réalité votre
truc à vous c'était le foot à
fond un plan Mbappé fait avant avant
Kimba NES alors il était né en 2005 mais
il était pas gr hein ouais ouais tout
simplement parce que je trouve je pense
que je suis tombé sur des encadrants des
éducateurs qui avaient envie de de me
tirer du terrain qui était derrière chez
moi et du terrain de foot du club et
voilà ils m'ont pointé du du doigt en me
te disant petit gamin tu es pas mal il
fa toi tu as quelque chose tuas quelque
chose et et à partir de ce moment-là bah
tu te sens considéré sincèrement tu te
sens considéré tu te sens vu et que tu
es pas pointé du doigt dans le mauvais
sens où attention c'est ah attention il
y a quelque chose qui est bien qui est
très positif viens faire un tour sur
notre terrain c'est bien il y a y a des
copains aussi et il y a quelque chose il
y a quelque chose à faire et à partir de
ce momentl bah j'ai senti qu'il y avait
une envie je me faisais bah j'étais aimé
j'étais aimé de tout le monde hein mais
il y avait un un petit truc et puis un
peu admirer ouais ouais et à partir de
ce moment-là bah je me suis laissé
porter et on est on est on est parti sur
le terrain je connaissais pas du tout ce
milieu cétait quelque chose de nouveau
j'avais pas envie de faire de
l'athlétisme je savais que je courais
vite j'avais pas envie de mettre de
collant j'avais pas envie de mettre de
pote de pote et de de courir sans pour
rien j'avais envie d'échanger avec mes
mes copains et en
fait au foot avec mes copains et en fait
je me suis rendu compte que dans un
groupe d'entraînement de gamins de mon
âge il y avait des gens qui venaient de
partout le paraître c'était secondaire h
tu pouvais pas montrer sa dernière paire
de chaussur comment tu était habillé
c'était tout le monde fait la même chose
il y avait une il y avait un groupe
d'entraînement fait de garçons de filles
qui venaient de divers milieu et ça m'a
plu ouais parce qu' on va resituer le
contexte vous êtes un enfant de la
banlieue parisienne on est donc au début
des années fin des années 90 début des
années 2000 donc ce fameux football dont
vous parlez est devenu du monde en plus
un truc de fou où chaque enfant qui a
quelques aptitudes se dit c'est ça que
je vais faire et donc vous vous
bifurquez sur sur
l'athlétisme vous on on vous dites mes
éducateurs ont vu quelque chose en moi
vous vous saviez que vous courez vite
mais à quel moment vous vous êtes dit je
vais sauter des non par c'est
sérieusement la j du courouré pour les
gens qui nous regardent et pour moi-même
c'est quand même une épreuve
d'athlétisme très particulière la ha
mais en fait ça voilà dans quand on
revient dans le contexte on se dit bien
que bah la génération Henry Anelka
Ronaldo R9 ça va très vite le vrai le
vrai ou le vrai ça pass des de certains
tacles ça mais ça ça joue avec de la
vitesse des over mars bon je je vais
m'arrêter là et donc l'objectif c'est
deevenir footballeur et je me dis si je
fais un peu d'athlétisme j'ai GIS encore
plus vite et je pourrais faire des
grands ponts les gestes techniques
c'était ça grand pont roulette audessus
de du corps ah ouais donc on fait de
l'atelé pour quand même être meilleur au
foot mais on laisse pas le le foot tout
de suite ouais on laisse pas le foot et
du coup j'ends j'apprends à faire du
Decathlon j'apprends à à lancer à sauter
à courir longtemps à courir vite à faire
des ha donc je touche un peu tout et
mais l'objectif c'est de faire du foot
quoi et je me rends compte que le milieu
est pas mal de la CL ouais pas mal et en
fait championat de France jeune je me
fais casser le
tibia et là bah le rêve s'arrête tout
simplement j'aurais peut-être pas fait
carrière en vrai mais j'avais quoi 14 14
15 ans 14 ans et je me fais voilà je
prends un tacle euh on dit simulation
c'est l'époque
Ravanelli dites ça parce qu'il est
italien est tombaéit facilement et du
coup bah j'ai un peu la haine contre le
football ce sport qui me que j'aime
tellement donc l'amour et laine son son
ami ouis et là je me dis bon bah non moi
c'était le football là j'ai pris je me
suis fait casser le tibia moi mon rêve
s'arrête et petit à petit bah il y a
l'équipe et les amis de de l'athlétisme
qui me disent de revenir c'est sympa
regarde tu vas apprendre à à courir pour
toi avec les copains ça sera pas pour
les autres et du coup tu t'es sacrifié
pour les autres et au final tu as eu ton
mal au tibia et en fait ça ça s'est
inversé j'ai j'ai commencé à faire du
décathlon et puis pour le 110 m c'était
bah je pense que c'était un peu dans le
même système
c'est la plupart des gens avaient peur
de passer des ha oui et moi
j'ai j'avais aussi peur mais en fait j'y
allais et du coup on a on est revenu
vers moi avec le doigt en disant c'est
pas mal ce que tu fais sur les ha tu
pourrais aller encore plus vite si tu
faisais ça faisais ça et du coup j'ai
j'ai vu qu'il y avait de l'intérêt et ça
m'a encore plu et dans la tête je suis
parti en me disant que je vais faire du
du 110 plus tard ouais et comment on
acquiert cette technique de
des parce que pour nous simple mortel on
court ok éventuellement on peut faire du
son en hauteur mais les deux en même
temps sur une distance de centimètres il
faut du rythme il faut de la précision
il faut de la puissance et il faut de la
vitesse mais comment vous faites ah bah
là c'est bah j'ai je pense que je suis
tombé amoureux de l'athlétisme après
coup
et je me suis intéressé à à la
discipline j'ai essayé de regarder un
peu regardez ça c'est c'est magnifique
c'est clair c'est magnifique je me suis
intéressé à ce qui s'était passé et les
grands champions Marie joperc notamment
j'avais vu dans les yeux de mon père bah
tout ce qu'elle avait fait donc du coup
je me suis inscrit vraiment en
athlétisme après 96
et et les grands champions donc il y
avait Colette Besson guide rue c'est qui
ce monsieur
guiderue il court il passe des e c'est
marrant ça c'est bien c'est pas
forcément le le plus rapide qui va
gagner c'est le plus malin c'est celui
qui va éviter les obstacles et ça Mo
c'est un peu un petit raccourci que je
veux dire mais ça me rappelait un peu
les les jeux que je faisais dans mon
quartier où tu tu rajoutais toujours un
petit une petite difficulté jongler
c'est bien mais jongler en alterant
alternant les jambes c'est bien euh le
tour du monde comme tout tout gamin a
fait passer par là et revenir là ça
change un peu ça te fait des petits
challenges donc faire la course contre
tout le monde c'est bon j'ai déjà fait
et je le fais en club pour le pour
apprendre pour le et là tu dis tu fais
la course et chaque haie est différente
chaque impulsion et réception c'est
différent et ça amène un petit truc qui
a fait que bah je suis tombé amoureux de
ça ouais vous avez parlé de guide rue
vous avez parlé de Stéphane Diagana il y
a donc vous maintenant euh dans cette
histoire- là il y a Caristan aussi ai
c'est c'est une très grande école euh et
maintenant et maintenant sur le la ha on
va parler de l'atelé
ouais accpagnez
accpagne on a perdu le savoir-faire
ou bien ça va revenir non je dirais
qu'on a on a le savoir-faire et
malheureusement après c'est mon avis
hein je je casse pas forcément le le
système mais je dis que je dirais tout
simplement que bah on est dans une
génération où il y a on fait attention
au data ouais vous allez voir au data
donc il faut faire des mises à jour si
tu fais pas de mise à jour tu es plus
dans le tu es plus dans le train toi tu
es plus dans le tu es plus dans le dans
l'air du temps on sait faire des
Champions et et on s'arrête sur on se
pose sur nos acquis tout simplement sauf
que la tendance à change à change à
change à change et les mecs qui font du
110 m aujourd'hui c'est des c'est des
sprinters purs c'est des gens qui vont
super viteou plus qu'à votre époque plus
qu'à à mon époque et plus qu'à l'époque
d'avant et les techniques d'entraînement
elle elles changent aujourd'hui quand on
regarde j'aime bien faire le le le
rapport avec le football parce que c'est
un sport très très populaire et les gens
s'intéressent un peu plus que l'athelet
je dirais malheureusement
euh le football d'aujourd'hui le gardien
est très important il faut qu'il joue
des deux pieds il faut qu'il sorte c'est
le c'est le 11e joueur pour de vrai pour
de vrai ouais et des systèmes de jeu qui
qui ont changé ça va le ballon va plus
vite queavant qu'avant et l'athlétisme
c'est pareil le 110 m et maintenant tu
as des pointures mais les techniques de
course elles changent les intervalles
sont toujours pareils les la musculation
change du coup il faut changer les
techniques parce que les gars les gars
sont plus grands plus fins il faut
adapter à chacun et et je dirais que en
général en
France je pas me faire de copain mais on
reste sur nos acquis parce qu'on sait
faire du coup on n pas besoin de
regarder à gauche ou à droite alors vous
maintenant vous êtes paré de l'autre
côté vous êtes éducateur alors vous avez
une assoce dont on va parler parce
qu'elle est formidable et puis vous
accompagnez aussi des des des sportifs
de haut niveau vos inspirations elles
viennent d'où elles viennent de
forcément de de ce que j'ai fait moi de
ce que j'ai fait avec mon entraîneur de
ce que j'ai pu vivre en tant que
sportif en allant à l'étranger j'ai eu
des concurrents j'ai regardé ce qu'il
faisait que ça soit
Lutang Tramel Jackson
Johnson et aujourd'hui il y a des
nations référen il y a des nations plus
on sait que les États-Unis c'est c'est
un gros vivier sur le 11 m ça l'a
toujours été sur toutes les disciplines
d'athelet beaucoup parce que que le
sport aux États-Unis est est différent
fait partie de de la culture de la vie
de la vie ouais et en France on a cette
chance là d'avoir des talents mais on a
pas cette culture sportive et encore une
fois je sais que je veux pas me faire
d'amis mais on n pas une culture
sportive parce que culture sportive ça
veut pas dire avoir des champions c'est
tout ce qui va derrière c'est de faire
du sport tout le temps c'est manger
dormir boire sport en tout cas c'est pas
un hobby c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
fait quand on a le temps ça devrait être
intégré voilà dans nos système
d'éducation mais c'est pas encore ça
pour moi je trouve que c'est pas encore
ça parce que aujourd'hui on a la chance
nous bah maintenant je suis entraîneur
et et je le vois avec Sacha que
j'entraîne qui est francoaustralien et
Zimbabwe alors Sacha Zoya parce que pour
nos téléspectateurs qui ne le
connaissent pas c'est l'un des plus
grands espoirs ouais de médaille pour
les jeux de 24 mais bien au-udelà parce
qu'il est très jeune Sacha euh vous avez
il vous a choisi vous l'avez choisi euh
il y a le modèle fédéral et puis il y a
vous en plus à côté cohabite ensemble
maintenant il y a des choses où euh bah
on gar Sacha quand il a il a fait appel
à moi il avait il m'a dit clairement je
sais que tu es un jeune coach on m'a pas
recommandé de de de m'entraîner avec toi
parce que tu débutes je dis je le sais
bien et c'est c'est le jeu maintenant
moi j'ai besoin de de T vécu d'athlète
et je sais que tu vas tout faire pour
que tu vas que tu réhausses ton niveau
de coach et que tu vas t'adapter à ce
qui se fait parce que ce qui me parle
c'est c'est ça va être ton vécu et ce
qui se passe sur le terrain ça qu'il est
venu chercher chez il est venu chercher
ça et je lui dis ok let's go à un moment
si jamais tu vois que ça bloque tu me le
dis on se parle entre hommees même si tu
as il a quand il arrivve il avait 17 ans
aujourd'hui il a 21 ans on a un rapport
de d'entraîneur entraîné manager
coaching tout on parle de tout et c'est
ce qu'il est venu chercher aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on fait on s'adapte à lui et
et ça à lui et à ce que j'ai vu est ce
que je peux voir ce que je peux aller
chercher ainsi de suite et c'est comme
ça qu'on évolue on va chercher des datas
partout et quand on a
un un talent bijou comme celui-là comme
ça bah on a une pression et comment on
arrive à le façonner est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on y est pour quelque chose est-ce
que c'est lui tout seul est-ce que c'est
la rencontre de plusieurs savoir-faire
et de plusieurs ambitions je pense que
c'est un tout tout simplement c'est
c'est c'est un environnement qui fait
que que ça marche c'est pas que
l'entraîneur ou que l'athlète ou que la
kiné c'est c'est un tout en fait en fait
on essaie d'avoir un équilibre on a un
objectif commun c'est de faire en sorte
qu'il progresse
mais il a progressé ouais on n pas
de on n pas de d'outil qui pourrait dire
bah tel gamin tu le scannes tu peux
l'amener jusque là on n pas ça ça existe
pas avec tel coach telle technique il il
devrait faire tel chrono ça existe pas
donc tu auras toujours des gens qui vont
dire ah il aurait dû faire c il devrait
faire ça aujourd'hui il progresse et on
est dans dans ce qu'on doit faire à
chaque début de saison comme tout coach
on a des objectifs je lui dis moi je
vaux t'amener là tel chrono tel truc tel
je sais que tu es capable de faire c
faire ça et pour l'instant ça marche oui
là le bois parce que parce que on est à
quelques mois d'une grande échéance dont
on espère et les ambitions elles sont
elles sont hautes bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'elle soit toujours haute parce que
parce que c'est un c'est un on va pas se
cacher c'est un talent et ce et ce ce
gamin là il faut que il garde cette
fougue et et qu'il a envie de tout
casser casser le jeu comme je disais
tout à l'heure comme vous l'avez fait
avec avec votre génération il y a 20 ans
il finissent le jeu il le casse faut
qu'il soit meilleur que vous ah oui faut
qu'il soit champion olympique un jour
qu'il fasse tout ce que j'ai pas pu
faire c'est quoi c'est ce que je lu dis
médaille olympique ou champion olympique
ça vous l'avez les premiers jeux c'était
il y a 20 ans pour vous c'est ça c'est
athè 2004 qu'est-ce que vous avez
éprouvé quand vous vous êtes retrouvé
dans la délégation olympique ah ouais
mais j'étais super fier ah les années
olympiques équipe de France l'armée
française du sport c'est c'était ouf ah
ouais mais c'est non mais c'est vraiment
c'est c'est c'est unique chose les jeux
c'est unique quand on est athlète non
mais là tu es gravé dans l'histoire mais
jusqu'à on le verra pas mais les
personne après nous il vont ils vont se
dire mais tu te rends compte ils ont eu
des jeux à telle telle période il y a eu
C il y a eu ça si tu excelles c'est non
mais c'est c'est juste ouf quoi c'est un
grand rendez-vous pour l'athlétisme
français dont on a dit depuis le début
de cet entretien qu'il a été qu' est
plus ou presque plus ou en tout cas
beaucoup moins où il y a une grosse
chute il y a plus d'école du sprint
français il y a d'un point de vue espoir
de médaill soyons sincère à part Kevin
Mayer sur le décathlon dont vous avez
parlé d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on n'est
pas sûr de pouvoir en cocher d'autres
est-ce qu'on se trompe la j courouré
quand on raisonne comme ça après c'est
compliqué de prendre prendre REP parce
que je ne sais pas ce que font les
autres moi j'entraîne trois gamins don
Sacha et nous on est dans notre voilà
dans notre autoroute on est là pour vot
couloir cou voilà dans le couloir et
nous c'est de tout faire pour qu'il soit
qualifié parce qu'il est qualifiable qu'
soit qualifié qu' soit performant aux
Jeux Olympiques championnat de France et
au Jeux Olympiques enfin le reste je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils font à tout moment
avec le public et tout on peut passer
l'autre côté et et et tout faire
exploser par jou ça joue beaucoup et moi
c sur des athlète dans un stadero mais
mais totalement il y a Renault la
vilennie qui raconte ce truc incroyable
en 2012 à Londres au moment où il est
dans sa finale il y a une ambiance de
fou alors c'est il dis je sais que c'est
pas pour moi parce que je ne sais plus
quel est le l'athlète
britannique qui rentre en en LCE mais il
dit j'ai tout aspiré et je suis champion
olympique aussi probablement grâce à ça
mais là tu reçois de l'amour de tout le
monde la fierté des gens des gens qui ne
regardent pas forcément le sport et des
étrangers qui se disent ou les Français
ils crient ah ben on va crier avec eux
parce qu'il y a une bonne ambiance mais
juste ça mais c'est c'est c'est non mais
là tu es un superhéros mais je pense
qu'ils sont pas encore au courant de ce
qui va se passer même nous on imagine
mais c'est juste génial c'est un
rendez-vous immense pour le sport
français la c'est un c'est un événement
mais c'est bah c'est le plus gros
événement français c'est le plus gros
événement mondial et il va se passer en
France l'équipe de France olympique et
c'est juste voilà il faut compter sur
sur le public et je pense que les
athlètes vont être prêts en tout cas en
athlet ils vont vont être prêts ils vont
tout donner en tout cas je le souhaite
et et c'est ce qui va faire ça passer
voilà quand tu arrives dans le dernier
carré au foot il y a plus qu'à ou le
plus compliqué c'est de passer les les
tours et puis voilà euh on on entend
quand même beaucoup de critiques autour
des jeux et cetera ça vous agace ça
m'agace et en même temps je suis
d'accord vous êtes d'accord avec quoi
avec plein de choses dans le sens
où ça agace les gens parce que on a
l'impression que tout le monde se plaint
on va pas être prêt on va pas être prêt
on va pas être prêt mais on a envie
d'avoir la sensation d'être prêt et
quand on quand on a envie d'être d'avoir
cette sensation on a envie que ben on
parle de partout des Jeux Olympiques et
et et là je reviens sur ce que je disais
où où j'étais en train de dire bah je
suis jaloux bah oui je suis jaloux et
j'ai pas l'impression que tout le
monde est prêt à accueillir les Jeux et
je me dis non mais réveillez-vous les
les gens il y a qu-ce qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait pour que
tout le mondece qui manque qu'est-ce qui
manque la culture sportive on en revient
toujours à ça ah ouais ça commence
maintenant et là tu as le téléphone tu
as les téléphones de tout le monde qui
sonnent les anciens athlètes et les
athlètes en en activité venez dans mon
école venez dans mon école faites la
promotion téléphone ah ouais il fait que
sonner ouais donc ça c'est plutôt bien
mais c'est plutôt bien mais sauf que là
on est à 6 mois
c'est trop tard 6 mois on a rien là mais
nous on peut pas se déplacer et faire la
promotion fallait y penser il y a 1 an 2
ans pour préparer tout le monde moi je
parle de ce sujet là après il y a plein
d'autres choses ça va être génial hein
je dis pas que mais c'est juste on
espère ouais c'est juste que bah cet
événement là avec le respect que j'ai
waouh faut s'y prendre il y a il y a
longtemps quoi il faut pas que ça soit
un événement ça passe et tout le monde
ah c'était génial tu as vu il y a une
fan zone on va aller voir pour un vert
il y a y a un match non non c'est les
Jeux Olympiques à Paris en 2024 vous ces
jeux vous allez les faire avec une
acraide autour du coup je ne sais pas ou
pas je ne sais pas je ferai tout pour y
être en tout cas j'espère que j'aurai
une accredde c'est pas c'est pas gagné
ça ne dépend pas de de de ma fédération
ou la Fédération olympique c'est ça
dépend les quotas ouais mais ça c'est
très difficile à expliquer pour le grand
public qui pense que à partir du moment
où on travaille autour du sport on a
accès à tout en fait c'est un événement
extrêmement élitiste y compris pour ceux
qui sont dans la mécanique même et la
fabrication je m'entends de champions
c'est ça qui est paradoxal c'est que tu
peut-être que vous allez les regarder à
la télé ces jeux c'est ça que vous êtes
en train de nous dire peut-être que je
vais être à la maison maison de la
performance ouais ou au Club France Club
France ouais ouais moi j'ai pas envie
d'être là-bas vous avez envie d'être
jamais il est qualif de France la deè m
des Jeux Olympiques où se joue
l'athlétisme ah ouais si si tout va bien
et qu'on qu'il est qualifié moi je veux
ah non c'est je suis à côté de to je
suis à côté de toi et tu as besoin je
suis écoute quand il faut temporiser si
jamais il s'échauffe il est excité bah
tu connais ton gars tu V dire e tout va
bien tu es prêt il y a d'autres si tu es
pas là peut-être que bah la course ça
peut passer à côté parce que c'est
possible personne le connaît personne
peut le temporiser
exemple mieux que vous mieux qu'un
n'importe quel entraîneur qui suit son
son son équipe ou son athlète et c'est
juste ça qui est un peu mais bon s'il
faut passer la barrière je la passerai
hein on est déjà passé plus de 10 ce que
j'allais dire c'est votre spécialité
pour terminer vous êtes au tour on l'a
dit de jeunes grands champions mais pas
seulement avec une association que vous
avez créé vous allez aussi chercher des
jeunes ouais pour leur faire faire de
l'athlétisme mais pas dans un stade pas
dans un club vous avez fait cette
attelée des des quartiers entre
guillemets ou de la rue c'est nécessaire
d'aller les chercher ces jeunes parce
qu'ils viennent moins à l'athlétisme
qu'avant ils viennent pas tout
simplement faire du sport ou ils
viennent beaucoup moins qu'avant parce
qu'avant avant on avait la chance
d'avoir des des profs qui étaient aussi
éducateurs à l'école et donc éducateurs
au
centre de sport de la ville et du coup
le le le le relais était facile quoi tu
faisais du sport à l'école et puis le
prof te poait du doigt en disant bah
viens cet après-midi faire de la S et
viens au club le soir et le relais était
facile aujourd'hui ils sont tellement
submergés par d'autres travaux je dirais
ça comme ça que il y a beaucoup moins de
de de ponts qui qui sont faits et comme
on n' pas la culture du écoute tu fais
rien aujourd'hui va va faire du sport
là-bas bah il faut il faut recréer des
ponts et l'association c'est ce qu'elle
fait et en
et et la génération d'aujourd'hui est le
plus jeune donc entre les 8 et et 16 ans
il faut trouver des techniques qui font
que bah
tu tu t'intéresses à eux ils se sentent
intéressés du coup comme ce qui vous
êtes arrivé à vous fa voà ouais tout
simplement donc le code de l'athlétisme
où tu viens on te prend ton chrono oui
c'est bien il faut ça c'est les
spécialistes moi là avec l'association
et et les gars de l'association le but
c'est de faire une animation autour de
la musique autour d'une ambiance qui
fait que bah ils vont passer une bonne
journée ils vont avoir une méga envie de
revenir ouais et donc de faire du sport
parce que il y a un enjeu à la fois
d'émancipation d'intégration et de santé
publique on sait que les jeunes font de
moins en moins de sport et on est en
train de se préparer une bombe à
retardement dans 20 ans quand ils auront
40 ans et que la sédentarité
d'aujourd'hui ils vont la payer cash
c'est aussi le
rôle oui de chacun d'entre nous citoyens
engagés de c'est notre rôle de de les
sensibiliser à tout ça et d'essayer de
faire des choses parce qu'ils ne se
rendent pas forcément compte ce ils ont
envie certains c'est faire que des jeux
vidéos j'en fais moi aussi mais un peu
venez sur le terrain venez discuter
c'est une génération c'est une
génération qui a plus de tentation entre
guillemets que les
nôtres non oui oui je dirais plus de
tentation mais en même temps c'est la
communication c'est c'est la clé de tout
quoi il suffit juste de bien communiquer
comme eux si tu communiques comme eux et
qui qui que que les messages arrivent à
à passer bah ça ça le fait on y
arrive et il y a plein d'associations
qui arrivent aussi maintenant il faut
ouais il faut savoir communiquer et
c'est la clé du du succès je dirais vous
avez conscience de du rôle qui est le
vôre aujourd'hui pour terminer la pour
j'ai
pas je pense que j'ai pas forcément le
conscience du rôle que j'ai j'ai juste
envie de d'aider et de partager je suis
passionné donc à partir du moment o je
suis passion vous vous sentez pas
investi d'une certaine mission quand
même
des fois un peu mais j'ai pas
d'obligation mais je me sentirais pas
bien je sais que je me sentais je me
sens pas bien quand je j'essaie pas de
faire des choses ou j'essaie je laisse
passer le train je vois des gens qui ne
font rien je me dis mais non là
tu as eu la chance d'avoir rencontré des
des des personnes dans ta vie qui t'ont
fait aimer un truc que jamais de la vie
jeune j'aurais pensé c'est ton rôle un
peu mais tu es pas obligé tu aurais pas
aimé qu'on t'oblige
à toi de trouver quelque chose pour que
donner envie donner
envie les mecs en face de toi il sont
ils sont comme
toi le voyage est génial moi j'ai en
tout cas le voyage aujourd'hui je
continue à voyager hein mais je voyage
de de de sportif de gamin de quartier
qui a fait du sport qui est qui a fait
le tour du monde mais aujourd'hui je
suis super fier de tout ça et j'en je
remercie tout le monde quoi toutes les
personnes que j'ai que j'ai croisé c'est
juste ouf aujourd'hui je à côé en face
de vous vous avez trouvé le bon mot
c'est est un voyage votre vie merci en
tout cas de nous avoir permis de voyager
un peu avec vous la D de couré